them so she's talking to bakker of yahoo
and she's cursing the pros and i'm
changing his name calling him
adding the lowest or the curse the curse
and he's sitting there and she's saying
where is your saheb and al-baqarah
like looking like he's right there but
rasam had made
oh allah don't let her see me right
because he didn't he didn't engage in
those kinds of lowly conversations
when it happened and told her are you
going to
told rasulullah are you going to respond
to her look at the beautiful response
rasulullah
said why should i respond to her she's
not speaking about me
i'm muhammad whoever she's talking about
that's not me so let them respond right
and subhanallah i mean like
look at how he dealt with that situation
we need to learn
from that example right so if somebody
gets
vulgar with us we cannot get vulgar back
with them sometimes you have to be firm
i mean i'm not trying to say be soft
like a social would not start
if somebody was aggressive he would he
would put him in their place and that's
how we have to be too
we're not trying to turn the other cheek
and that's all that's all hypocrisy
anyway we've challenged many
christian preachers at the park there's
videos we tell them do you really
believe that they said yes that's
all right let me come and slap you right
here right now we'll put it to the test
let me
you know let me go do it let me see you
turn the other cheek and none of them
will step up
because it's hypocrisy they say one
thing and they do the other
in islam we don't believe in hypocrisy
we say what we do and we do what we say
sha allah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
surround yourself with good people not
bad people if you're in a position where
those around you are influencing you
negatively
more than you're influencing them
positively i think you need new friends
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the dunya the three muslims podcast
we're joined today with a very special
guest
masha allah sheikh of man eben farooq
and for those of you who don't know
he's a very special guest why but
because he actually has
a phd in david wood refutations
masha'allah
he uh recently engaged in an
intellectual
street fight masha'allah it was actually
like what three on one four and one a
thousand to one well i couldn't i
couldn't tell at that point subscribe
it's good to see you guys good to be on
here i like i like the realist
mashallah podcast i like real man
which is exactly why we are one time we
are on today masha'allah
i'm actually enrolled in a phd program
and i was wondering how did these guys
know i haven't even told
anybody man
mommy got some secret service guys
watching me or what
subhanallah man after that uh that
massacre on david wood and them i think
you you might have some people watching
you so may allah protect you bro
you know they could watch me all day
long man people say like people got your
phone tapped water i mean they can tap
my phone all day long what are they
gonna listen to
he's going to the masjid
[Laughter]
so if you don't mind me asking what's
the uh what's the phd for
um actually so i have two masters right
now i have an executive mba that's
a technology management then i have one
in hadith i actually enrolled in a phd
program
in regulatory and uh quality compliance
that's
as you can see i'm at the work at the
office i work a regular job i don't take
money from the mazda or from omf or
anybody else or anything
so i actually applied for a phd program
in uh
my business field i also inshallah i
want to apply for a phd in
islamic field i applied at imam sarut
before but
i got stuck in a 20-30 review or
something like that so whatever we'll
we'll move forward in sha allah so
inshallah what's best for you and great
success
so you mentioned um the uh the dawah
network you're a part of
um so subhanallah i wanted to ask after
watching that
that discussion i have a few questions
about uh one that the daoa foundation
and and two about dawa and street dawa
in general so
firstly do you wanna you know give this
take this opportunity to shout out the
foundation
so yeah alhamdulillah we have the one
message foundation um
it's very good sincere brothers
mashallah our brother mukarram our
brother
our brothers brothers mashallah there's
a lot of brothers
that are involved may allah reward all
of them
and there was before that there was dr
tarabishi he started a
thing called the islamic charity
foundation icf and basically they're all
really good brothers good good man hajj
and they
started this uh like you know
they didn't take a salary they didn't
take any kind of cuts just
put it out there and alhamdulillah they
invited me to join with them and
i just i mean i'm the least productive
of the team
i just show up you know so they do all
the hard work of you know getting all
the permits and getting the materials
and doing all the stuff
and i just lazily show up late and
uh but you know so allah accepted from
all of us
and there are other brothers i mean we
have the one message foundation
mashallah
they're there on sunday there are some
other brothers who are not an omf they
come on saturdays do the da'wah as well
we have other brothers in different
parts and may allah reward everybody i
mean alhamdulillah we want to give a
shout out to everybody who is doing
one message foundation masha allah is
some of you may have noticed they just
hit 100 000
subscribers
so that's great and i really want to
take this opportunity to thank uh
hammer time hashumu and the crooks
um for helping us you know i think we
grew like maybe 30
something thousand subscribers and stuff
just from that one video
yeah from that one video i think yeah so
nice and also i mean uh more importantly
i think
we're definitely past 30 known jahadas
from that video
uh there's a video we just posted uh
omaha just posted i think this morning
um if you haven't seen it check it out
it's uh we had a
ex a former christian pastor
from connecticut that came out to san
diego to see us
from having watched that video and many
and after that many other videos
and masha'allah i mean it's a really
good conversation
and you can see that uh the tafseer of
the ayah
makarova is being explained in front of
our eyes
because they made their plan they made
their plot we had i mean
people don't realize like we had no idea
because we just show up
every sunday for years we've been going
out there
we don't know who's going to come up
like it could be atheists it could be
jews it could be christians it could be
hindus we get all type we get people
that claim to have lived like seven
lives you know you'll see those weird
videos of people that are
kind of out there so these guys made a
plot and i mean from the video the crook
himself says that they were planning
this for months um and there's videos of
uh
hashu what's his hasumo actually
whatever his name is
um him out there talking about from
months i mean i don't watch their stuff
like i'm not subscribed to their
channels i don't watch your videos
so i don't know but he had been putting
these videos out for months saying
he's going to go out there and do all
kinds of things to us
and talk about all this stuff that he
talked um
i'll talk um but he showed up
they came on a saturday and i wasn't
there because i usually go sundays
and they mentioned the brothers told me
hey these guys came and they're going to
come and i had no idea who they were
to the extent that i had seen a picture
of david wood in a
women's lingerie dress or whatever uh
because somebody sent it to me
uh yeah i mean i'm not kidding yeah but
i never watched a video of him so if i
had seen him at
a grocery store i would not have known
it's him because he wouldn't unless he
was wearing the same lingerie
i think i have seen those anyway um
and uh i had seen some pictures of
hashimoto somebody had sent me like
short clips of him
going off or whatever but i didn't
really know him either i mean again if
i'd seen him in a grocery order
anthony i'd never heard of my life never
heard his name um
and i said he was these guys showed up
and then they expected me to know who
they are or something
like who are you guys right
and you know that prep all their stuff
but
we depend on have to walk with allah and
alhamdulillah
may allah reward the brothers from omf i
mean they you know they they've been
doing this
not just uh for debates i mean out there
for dawah
so alhamdulillah i mean before we go
further i want to give a quick shout out
to my mother
you are her favorite daddy in youtube so
when she brought you up to me she was
like hey
you gotta get a shake uh with him on
eben farooq on this podcast i was like
shaykh with man i've heard a little bit
about him found the video and
a couple minutes in your coined or
deemed the shooter
so my first question is why why why is
that a nickname bro
um oh man
i so i didn't coin that uh when i was
young
i grew up uh with gangs and stuff and
the mexican gangs
and as you may know gangs give you a a
name you know so you don't really choose
it they give it to you
so like for example if some guy was uh
you know
a big guy maybe you call him oso or
something like bear or somebody
uh you know sometimes they were uh a guy
would be called
boxer or diablo or travis or whatever
right
uh i was always an avid fan of guns
so uh without getting any more detail
into why they called me shooter they
called me shooter
um so that's that's how i got and again
i don't really
usually mention that but in the
conversation with anthony
uh he kind of brought up his uh supposed
gang world
ties but as you can tell from the video
he was never an actual gang member
uh inglewood mafia is a black gang he
claimed their essays
and then he wasn't actually a member and
from his personal traits they gave him
the name crook
which he said so when i call him the
crook i'm not making fun of him i well i
kind of am but
but i'm actually using the name he put
forward so
uh in my gang world they called me
shooter so that's uh that's where the
name had come from and he asked
otherwise usually i don't mention it so
um i have a lot of reasons i could give
you more details of why
but then that'll probably be problematic
we'll keep that to uh off camera thing
but uh just so far man just watching the
work that you're doing man tremendous
work man barakallah feet
it takes a lot of courage to defend the
umma and a lot of honor
and a lot of people are kind of a little
soft they're like you know i don't want
to say much i want to
come across a little over pious you know
should i say something
so what keeps you on the forefront
to just be fearless and dealing with
islamophobes people that are just
attacking islam um
i don't know it's a good question um to
be very honest i don't really think it
through that much you know
my father and allah have mercy on him
and he used to tell me one thing he said
you know
it's a personal saying i don't know if
i'll just translate it you know he goes
don't overthink things or it uh weakens
the resolve
right meaning you know you you kind of
see what
you have to do what's right you do it in
the right way and then you just do it
whatever happens happens you know
so we you know we know that that was a
responsibility upon us as muslims living
in the west
uh whichever way we may do it i mean not
everybody's going to be
in front of the camera or in front of a
boat you know somebody's going to be
like
like brothers masha'allah with your
podcast you're doing a great job
service for the ummah people that share
these videos and like the videos and
promote the videos they're doing their
part
people that financially support the
dawah they're doing their part and so on
so we saw a need that needed to be felt
filled and we just did it and
whatever comes comes you know like let
them come and i mean we have nothing
we're ashamed of in this religion
alhamdulillah we have nothing we're shy
about in this religion we don't
censor any questions they can ask any
question they like so they
prepare for months like each time that
you know and david came out twice
and some other ones that come out they
prepare for months and these guys
brought other pastors with him they had
uh this other dude that was in the video
asking some question there so it was not
just three of them
probably about 20 of them that came out
from different areas different
places and that funding and all that so
they prepare all these questions to try
to trick us but for us we just depend on
allah
and we alhamdulillah our to love our
students of knowledge our god we have
the rules to teach them knowledge
and then we talk whatever they ask let
them ask we our religion is so beautiful
and so perfect that there is nothing
they can ask that will that will put us
on like the back footing you know
alhamdulillah
we respond to everything and we continue
to go out and do it just
allah and then allah gives you the
nusrah you know it's not because i'm a
good debater
i'm not it's not because i'm intelligent
i'm not it's because allah
supported us and we continue to depend
on allah to support us
beautiful answer masha allah so now i
have a question about dawah
so straight down is is something that
has really blown up
you know in the recent like decade i'd
say you know speaker's corner and all of
these places
um it's almost as if people when they
see that style of dawah they're more in
tune because it's
back and forth it's more dramatic it's
like almost like a reality tv show
subhanallah
um and i honestly think you know it does
have some
my question to you will obviously ask
her but um there's just a discussion
you know of the pros and cons of it
but my question to you would be do you
recommend people do street dawah and and
what are the benefits or possible
possibly the cons of giving street dava
so
the the the point should always be
do dawah in the capacity that you're
able
right so like uh i wouldn't suggest
uh like our sisters go out on their own
and sit on the stream corner and call
people to islam because
you know the harm that could come to
them and you know we've been attacked
i mean as you can see there's videos of
reuben israel when they came with their
signs and tried to
you know they were they weren't man
enough to really take it to the next
level
but you know they tried right but allah
protected us kuffar came and made a
circle around us you can see the video
it's online so i mean
so so there are dangers to it so again i
wouldn't put everybody in that place
secondly people that may not know enough
to go and do street dao i shouldn't do
street dial up until you know
but
but you should know that verse right so
if you're going to go out there
and talk and this is one of the the
downsides of street dawah that i do see
is people go out there
and say things that are not correct
islamically
for them to be able to win the debate
and we don't do that
you know no matter i mean many people
does oh you shouldn't have said this you
shouldn't have said this don't say this
you know what i'm gonna say what's right
and i don't with hikma i mean i'm not
going to be like
rude about it but i'm going to say
what's right and then it is what it is
like they can call whoever they want
they can do whatever they want
we're not we're not worried about that
it's not upon us except to convey the
message clearly right
so now if you don't know enough then
don't be out there on the street giving
down i mean go and learn
your place then is to be a taliban to go
seek knowledge we have videos on uh we
have another channel called
where we have it's more focused towards
muslims so we have videos
about afrida we have a new series on
which is going to be on omf and which is
the seerah
the life of rasulullah sallam from
authentic hadith
so if you don't know then go learn right
and the tao of videos may allah the word
all the brothers involved
again i'm just there i mean a lot of the
editing a lot of the work that brothers
do
they've been putting all the verses on
the screens you know the bible verses
you know the quranic verses
so if you don't know watch those videos
and write down those verses and learn
when you know enough and you are in a
place where you can convey the message
do it and then if you get there with a
question that you don't know
very important all the say
i don't know and allah knows best and
i'll get back to you but some of the
brothers out there you see them like
debating and then you know people send
me clips and stuff
and they'll say things that are outside
the boundaries of sharia
to defend the point and then you lost
we as muslims can't lie in debates we
don't have this tapia and all this stuff
that's not an islamic concept right
you'll see uh in our video that we catch
christians lying like straight lying and
then we'll tell them like hey you know
it's a lie
and they'll still go with it right to
defend whatever corrupted
me that they have right we as muslims
can't do that
ends do not justify the means for us
what is uh the usual
is that the qasid like your
your goal has the ruling of the means
you take to get to it
right so if you lie and you get 30
shahadah you didn't get any of that
reward because you lied
right so you got to speak the truth you
got to keep it within the halal right
some of the brothers out there doing the
aw they indulge in things
that are outside what the islamic
allows right meaning they make uh
tawilat of uh
sifat or ayat or things which again is
against the way of the salaf of this
ummah
and and all the things that they indulge
in
you know we we don't we are quran we
we stick to what allah said and what the
prophet
said and that's our and that's what
we're sticking with and
whether somebody likes it doesn't like
it doesn't matter to me so
masha allah masha allah so i feel like a
lot of people are going to have the
question
of you know i don't know that much i'm
never going to know everything
at what point do i you know go out and
give dhaba because the hadith beautiful
hadith mentioned for the prophet
um convey um convey for me even if it's
just one ayah
um what if all i know is when i should i
go give dawah or at what point
should i you know so again that is not
like uh
i can't say if you memorize these many
hadith in this united then you should
give dawah because the shady i didn't
set those right
and that's one of the beautiful things
about the sharia it's applicable at all
times in all places
so it takes earth and and the the the
situation mccann and zaban into
consideration
meaning if you know enough about about
and again remember your that was towards
the oneness of allah
your that was not an attack on
christianity you don't need to know the
bible
that's that's stuff that we use when
people come with a preset mind to kind
of open their mind but in the end
even in the debate if you look at the
end of the debate uh i gave a
summary about boheid and that was the
point
of our dawa right so if you know enough
about that that you feel that you can go
out there and handle the
questions that usually you get then go
out there right
but my suggestion is everybody should
get a teacher
like everybody should have a share
everybody should have a mentor everybody
should have
somebody that they can they can reach
out to and i know that's very difficult
nowadays because scholars are few
i mean even around the world let alone i
mean in the west i don't think
we have anybody that can really reach
the level of what we would consider to
be
the ummah right but even in other
countries the scholars have become
fewer and fewer but we need to have
people we can
say hey
what do you think is the best use of my
abilities and you know kind of
kind of work with somebody who can help
you um if you have that if you don't
have that then you kind of have to
engage
your own abilities and your situation
like let's say you're in prison um
you know people know nothing but it's a
great opportunity if you know a few
ayats and you know the base of
that do your dawah with it but just keep
in mind if you don't know it's okay to
say i don't know
i'll get back to you you are not there
to impress people
you are there to convey a message if you
convey it wrong or incorrectly
you will be held accountable in front of
allah nobody will know
everything like if you think i'm going
to wait to become abnetamia
before i give dawah you will never be
like
so that's just not going to happen right
so everybody kind of has to
kind of evaluate their situation and if
they go out for example and they start
doing some street tawa
and they realize they don't know they
need to have a resource of knowledge
like a person of knowledge they can go
back to a scholar
uh and if you don't have it
alhamdulillah at least the youtube
videos will help you
because when you watch the videos you
can you can kind of learn but there's
not i mean
there's nothing new under the sun like
to say right meaning a lot of the
questions you're going to get in the
street table we've already got
right so you can see the answers how
their answers what are the verses what
are they
so if you watch the videos enough
inshallah you can get a good
base now there is something i'm trying
to work on but
unfortunately due to lack of time and
not being able to clone myself
i have not had time to work on because i
want to make a dawah field man i want to
make a little book
and it's going to be free like i don't
try to make money off this and it's
going to have the basics of the islamic
afrida
and a a chapter for how to give thou
to christians how to give power to jews
how to give doubts hindus
how to give dawah to atheists and then
sections on like
responses to common questions that
people will give you you know kind of a
little
field manual right and then inshallah it
would be a good guide for everybody
make dua that allah gives barakah in our
time so we can
get the project out and then we're gonna
post free pdf online if we print them
we're going to give them a free you know
it's not we're not we're not trying to
make money off this we're just trying to
get that from them
i mean honestly i think that's an
amazing idea because it's upon allah
you know when you when you have a person
out giving dawah and
you know they come across somebody uh
the reason they end up lying is
sometimes
because they they don't want to say i
don't know whether that's because of
arrogance or they don't want
to make the person feel like there might
not be an answer they
they abstain from saying oh i just don't
know but if they were to have something
like that something they can refer to
subhanallah
you know may allah allow it to happen
all right i got a question hit me so
my brother there's a lot of people when
they give dawah
they get really passionate and
we both know or we all know how
untamed emotion is the enemy of
performance right
so if if these people are getting
passionate they might be getting angry
or they might be getting excited about
something like
how can these people just relax and calm
down in these situations
that's a great question and i i get that
question
phrased a little bit differently from
many different people in the end
the answer is you have to look at the
life of the prophet salallahu
look rasulullah was hit with much
harsher situations
than us and he kept his cool right
imagine five
imagine the quraysh in mecca imagine and
you're making salah and
throwing i need the enter signs of a
camo on your neck
know i imagine your own uncle's walking
behind you and saying you're alive
so i always get inspiration from the
life of the prophet salallahu and that's
why
i taught seerah before but the early
gurus weren't recorded because the time
we didn't really record
and i'm doing it again and i'm hoping
people will watch it as a training
manual like they're not gonna
it's not gonna be entertaining like i
don't care about entertaining people
right
but it's it's to show us how we should
deal
with those types of situations because
the best example is the example of the
prophet salallahu when i'm out there
and people say stuff trust me i i mean
personally
if you knew me before islam i had a bad
temper to begin with but
alhamdulillah i've been able to control
and and
and keep my calm the best i can uh
because of that is that i think back at
our beautiful example
our role model right and think okay how
would he deal with situations like this
and it allows me to control my personal
emotions and be able to convey a message
and that's what every day has to do
man i wanted to i want to quickly touch
on a point that you know as muslims or
our example is very important and having
good speech
is highly underrated and
underappreciated today you see kids just
cussing out swearing out so
going to that man tell us a little bit
about why as muslims we shouldn't swear
we should be
very modest in our speech and if you
know we are
at a point in our life where things just
slip off quick on the tongue
how we can have the restraint you know
again for me i always back to our go to
who's our room or who's our
example right and our role model first
and foremost is rasulullah
and as we know from the hadith that was
never
vulgar in speech or in action he never
was fashion he never
he never allowed that speech to be
around him
right even when uh if you know the
hadith
where the yahoo they tried to play with
the words of salaam
right they would say they would try to
change it up to poison and that's beyond
you
and i started having that
veda that she had that that love for the
prophet saw salam and these people's bad
actions she replied them not with any
curse words
she didn't see anything uh any like a
profane word but she said yani
uh yeah he made the the punishment upon
you oh is
actually responded you know as a person
should to somebody trying to do
something like that
and the person told her it's upon you
not to use
uh this type of language just just say
wali
using some harsh words
in poetry against the prophet sallam
calling
yani from muhammad to madame the one who
is
cursed instead of the one who's praised
right so she was choosing very harsh and
allah made it
that she could not see the prophet even
though he was sitting there like this is
one of the miracles
because allah protected the honor of
rasool allah sallam
so she's talking to and she's cursing
the pros and i'm changing his name
calling him
adding the lowest or the curse the curse
and he's sitting there and she's saying
where is your sahib and al-baqarah
like looking like he's right there but
don't let her see me right because he
didn't he didn't engage in those kinds
of
lowly conversations when it happened
told her are you going to told
rasulullah are you going to respond to
her
look at the beautiful response
rasulullah said why should i respond to
her she's not speaking about me
i'm muhammad whoever she's talking about
that's not me so let them respond right
and subhanallah i mean like
look at how he dealt with that situation
we need to learn
from that example right so if somebody
gets uh
vulgar with us we cannot get vulgar back
with them sometimes you have to be firm
though i mean i'm not trying to say be
soft like a son would not stop
if somebody was aggressive he would he
would put him in their place and that's
how we have to be too
we're not trying to turn the other cheek
and that's all that's all hypocrisy
anyway we've challenged many
christian preachers at the park there's
videos we tell them do you really
believe that they said yes it's
all right let me come and slap you right
here right now we'll put it to the test
let me
you know let me go do it let me see you
turn the other cheek and none of them
will step
up because it's hypocrisy they say one
thing and they do the other
in islam we don't believe in hypocrisy
we say what we do and we do what we say
sha allah right so in islam
i'm not going to let anybody man handle
me i'm not going to anybody punch me i'm
not going to let anybody
try to you know i'm not going to be weak
to it but at the same time
i'm not going to lose my composure and
my
boundaries right uh so this is where we
have to look at
the actual example of our prophet
salallahu and bring it
think about this i mean when we use
vulgar words and things like this
who are we disgracing ourselves
i mean my father again allah reward him
uh he used to give me some advice he
said you know
if if you're walking and a dog's barking
at you
right everybody's going to say look at
that you know foolish dog
is barking right but if you start
barking back at the dog
who's the idiot you are why are you
barking at a dog
right so if somebody gets vulgar that's
their problem but if you get vulgar back
now it becomes your problem right um
that's so true my my teacher when i had
this discussion with him
he uh he would mention that listen what
they do they're accountable for
and they will be held accountable for it
by allah the day of judgement but what
you do
despite what they do you will also be
held accountable for us upon allah so
honestly it couldn't be truer so i guess
essentially we have to defend our honor
honorably
and not disgrace ourselves by trying to
defend it disgracefully so may allah
protect us from that
make us closer and more like the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
all right so here's another question if
someone's getting real heated
and they're thinking to themselves okay
what would the uh prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam do
and it's it's just not doing it for them
that the the heat is just rising and
rising
what do they do then they just cut it
off no no listen
if they're trying to give dawah like it
shouldn't be ending up in a fist fight
it shouldn't shouldn't i'm over here
looking at romney's over here
um i'm saying look you know um
if if somebody you know we're out there
right
if somebody takes a swing gun right i'm
gonna punch him right back
you know why because i'm not a pun and
nobody's gonna come get over on me i'm
i'm not anybody's you know ragdoll right
that's that's just the way i roll right
i don't want it to get to that right if
it's getting heated
you know you can walk away you can just
end it you can do whatever
but at the same time i mean you know
look
as muslims we can't be we can't be taken
as
as as punks either you know because what
happens is
when you let somebody punk you once
they're gonna punk you twice in three
times that's why that turning of their
cheek stuff doesn't work
you turn to their cheek and sooner or
later you'll be turning some other cheek
and you don't want to go into all that
right
so somebody got that right um
so so as a muslim
if it gets to be where it's it's not
productive in the conversation and
what i do and i know a lot of people
like in their comments they're like oh
you should just ignore these guys
like they don't understand when you're
out there doing that well you can't
really ignore somebody
that's like trying to heckle you right
you got to shut them up right
but you got to set them up academically
you know intellectually not physically
right
so you got you got to catch them on
something and then just end them right
like like i don't know if you guys seen
that video we had that
uh chaldean arab christian dude that was
like you know we were having a
conversation with some catholics and
these guys came in and tried to like
jump in and
heck go and use all kinds of weird stuff
and you know i just waited till we
caught them on something the guy was
like i've been to pakistan
oh man bro that guy was so annoying bro
that one right
everybody in the comments like you
should have just ignored him right and
talked to that girl
which they don't watch the second video
there's another video where we have that
we complete the conversation with that
girl and her
friend and all the catholics as well so
it's not like we ignored her but
at that time i couldn't ignore him
because if i ignored him he'd just keep
interrupting me and i couldn't have a
conversation
so we caught him i caught him on that
you've been to pakistan yeah what have
you been affecting i never said i've
been to pakistan
yes you did bet on video right all right
so so that's the thing we have to shut
them up so that's i mean i didn't have
to get physical with them but
mentally intellectually we just shut
them up and then we
keep moving with the productive data
right so that's the kind of thing you
have to be able to do and now it takes a
lot of patience it takes a lot of hikma
it takes a lot of wisdom
and a lot of that comes with experience
it comes with time you know we ask allah
to increase us in our in our wisdom and
patience and
helen with you know forbearance as i say
and you know helen is such a beautiful
quality you know what
haleem means the one who is slow to
anger
allah he's so patient imagine how
patient allah is with
think about this and these people are
out there saying all this kind of crazy
stuff about allah
allah is there allah hears it allah sees
it but allah is so
patient with them that he's giving them
this opportunity right
so we need to be helene but at the same
time if something
you know somebody starts to push your
parents just be like look bro let's just
end this
because this is not going to go anywhere
well you know let's just walk away you
know and let it go
and if it comes to it defend yourself
i'm never going to i'm never going to be
like get beat up you know
yeah i say that man cause like i have
respect for you
and i have respect for every other man
out there
doing that dawah like face to face
because getting in the confrontation
where it has a very high potential to
turn into a fight that's easy
you know that you just you stay quiet
control your anger
and then if it pops off then you're
ready for it but like in a
in a conversation where like you have to
be
remembering facts and like relaying that
back out to them like that's difficult
because then when you start getting
angry
well you can't remember anything now
yeah that's true
and that's why you say like you know not
everybody should be at that
table or at the thing you know some
people they're they they're better
supporting you know they're better doing
other things because
you know uh we've seen duat and i'm not
mentioning names anything that
sometimes lose it as far as using curse
words and things because of the
situation
we saw i saw a clip from one he started
barking at them you know because he just
got frustrated
and then if you're that guy then maybe
that's not the job for you you know i
mean not
like even the sahaba not every sahabi
was good at every
right like some sahaba they were khaled
you know they were they were out there
in forefronts right some of the sahaba
they were they were the best at
memorizing and they were best at hadith
and they were best some are better quran
some are better at
other things right you need to know your
skill set
and yourself well enough to be able to
then use that for the religion
where you're needed right and that's one
of the problems we see some people watch
the video and they think oh yeah that's
going to be me
and then they go out there and then they
just end up shaming themselves in islam
and it's like
you know i mean i hate to say it bluntly
but i'm just going to blunt with you
guys because you know we're
we're open here right you know know your
place
right somebody you know you're really
good at organizing things why don't you
be in the background organizing you know
somebody's good at
being in the front and being able to
handle those situations then you need to
even like i don't like it to be honest
you know i mean it's not people think
like it's fun but it's not i mean i
don't get paid from it i don't get any
uh financial benefit the only thing i
mean that's gonna happen to me
is it it can possibly from a worldly
perspective harm me like you know my
bosses and
co-workers that see me out there and
i've got neighbors that walk by and see
me and stuff right they see me
destroying their belief set you know and
and you know
they watch these videos and stuff right
so he could financially obviously hurt
me but i don't care like you know for me
i do it for allah
allah will give me better risk right
it's stressful
like like i'm not gonna say you go out
there and you know i go out there
and usually i'm there on sundays from
two to five about right
and sometimes like this last sunday as
soon as i got there we were debating
until 5 30 6 o'clock that i was out
there we were debating
different groups came and debate debate
debate you know mentally you get you get
tired right you go home and you're like
oh man and i got a headache and
you know i'm i'm exhausted and then you
know it's difficult i mean on the family
and allah toward my family my wife and
kids and
the support that they give me my mom
allah reward her
and allah the word your mom i just want
to give a shout out as well
so uh uh you know
so you were talking about my mom uh
my little word all your moms man what's
up bro shout out to everyone's mom
yeah so right so
i mean if your mom's raised you guys
that you guys are doing the good work
you're doing they did a good job man
a lot of work i mean all right
and your dad's as well i mean of course
i don't want to give me hate mail after
this
what about the bad man so i was
yeah i was wondering that uh when when
you're giving dawah
or you know let's say money gets
involved in it
i know you you said one message
foundation you guys do get you know
donations and all that but you try to
separate yourself
and you you try to renew your intentions
how do you
create that divide between
doing something but also you know
staying true to yourself and being like
i don't need the money
so i mean the first thing is
right rasulullah told us every deed is
based upon
intention this is the first hadith
so why is that the first hadith because
those understood the importance of
checking your intentions
right so at omf uh
alhamdulillah even though i mean
we do have a paypal for example for
people to support
for buying materials and stuff we'd have
a really fun race you know
not much i mean sometimes at the majid
we would you know ask the brothers to
step up and
uh when the videos got popular we
started getting like
a lot of brothers just sisters just
wanted to help
so we said what should we do we
obviously we buy equipment we bought a
new camera we bought new mics we bought
a new laptop and things to work on
because those things were needed
we bought dhawa materials we bought a
new cover for the
for the tank we bought new stuff there
but we had a lot of money left so we
alhamdulillah
uh recently uh this is a kind of a
surprise and the video is going to be
coming out i think tomorrow
inshallah is a thank you video for the
hundred thousand subscribers which is
going to show
we got a billboard now and it's uh
inshallah you'll see the billboards i
saw it man jesus jesus
yeah well it says jesus is uh jesus
returning
jesus a muslim are you right and you
know
people are like oh it's too strong
whatever you know it is what it is man
it's truth right um so
we took that money and alhamdulillah we
got a billboard and now we're gonna
we're gonna start
uh hiring people we're gonna because you
know we can't expect somebody to
man a phone and do all of that uh you
know without without some kind of way
for them to pay their bills
so inshallah we're gonna get brothers to
be paid for making sure that that was
done
and there's nothing wrong with that but
in the end it all goes to your intention
like me personally even if omf starts to
make millions
i'm not going to take a penny why
because this is my personal
prerogative this is my personal decision
that
even the masjid that i teach at i have
just made a decision because i've seen
too many people
fall off from that slippery slope
there's nothing wrong with getting paid
for dawah there's nothing wrong with
getting paid for bleeding salah
or teaching quran or teaching hadith and
things like that nothing wrong with that
at all
but everybody has to check themselves
you have to check your
intention and that's that's the hard
part right um
we have not mentioned names that we
tried to invite
and they would ask for like 10 grand for
a weekend and
two first class tickets and two suites
and
uh you know and things like uh yeah
actually i think it was more than two
tickets they wanted their secretary and
their wife
and they're this and they're that with
all you know business class words and
they're like
you know i mean i think we should treat
our and our well don't get me wrong
but if you start doing it where i mean
we had somebody that
we were discussing and he said if you
don't get this kind of money and this
kind of turnout then i'm not going to be
there and it's like
where's your intention then i like like
i get invited to a lot of podcasts and
stuff and
i never check how many subscribers they
have i never check how because
if you have one subscriber or a million
to me it's the same
because i'm doing it for a lot it's
allah hears me right
so it doesn't really matter to me when i
teach if i get one student or a hundred
thousand students
to me in the end it's the same you know
because for me
i'm doing it for allah as long as allah
accepts my intention
i'm successful right ambiya will show up
on the day of judgment with no followers
does that mean they're failures no
they're successful because they did
their job
right so that's the thing i mean
obviously you need funds to spread
dollars right
i mean somebody's got to pay for those
pamphlets somebody's got to pay for
those books somebody's got to pay for
that den
somebody's got to pay for those you know
whatever equipment that you're using
and and we really appreciate everybody
that mashallah even though we didn't
really ask that really
stepped up and requested and and donated
right
but at the same time if they didn't i'd
still be doing that with whatever i can
you know that's that's it and for those
of you all watching wondering why is
there a whiteboard behind shake with man
it's because you're at work right it's
about what 4 45 p.m
your time i'm wearing my you know
regular work clothes
and i'm i'm i'm at work this is those
are my tasks that i have to get done in
things
he's the muslim the muslim clark kent
i need to get some
[Music]
who's that guy i don't know it's not a
smile i don't know him bro
where'd you go where'd she go um yes so
just wondering so you have i'm assuming
you have a family
you're out here you know full-time job
four kids you will see some of them in
the dawah one of the one of the video
when i wasn't there one of my sons my
eldest friend yusuf
he's the one that answered a lot of the
questions and debated with some
and he was i think i've seen him yeah
yeah so he's i have a
son named yusuf uh he just graduated
masha'allah
with baraka in his studies and his time
and then i have a second
after that uh he is 15
and he does a lot of the video editing
mashaallah allah reward him for it
and then i have two younger daughters
that are six
and four so i have four kids uh
alhamdulillah married alhamdulillah i
have uh
i mean i'm a contractor right now but i
do have a full-time
work job i guess you could say i work in
the medical device industry in
regulatory and compliance
um i also teach i am teaching on
wednesdays we have a small book called
almost in the proof of quran hadith and
things
and then on saturdays we have the seerah
nabiya right now going on in
sahih and all those are free all of our
classes are free
all our programs are free they're
they're posted online you can watch them
free you can and and i just want to say
for our videos
if anybody wants to take them and make
because i don't have tick tock like i'm
not a tick talker i don't i don't i
don't have tick tock we don't have a
tick tock accounting people take them
make clips and put them on tik tok allah
bless them for it we don't care like we
don't copyright anything
we don't need you to i'll even say that
if you want to take my video and take my
face out and put your face in
go for it as long as
that was spread that's all we care about
i'm the luck so that begs the question
how does someone like yourself manage
your time
not easily
you know i just don't sleep a lot be
honest with you
so first thing is i get i want to send a
shout out to all the other brothers that
are involved because a lot of the work
gets done that you don't see the
brothers you know they're in the
background
they're organizing everything um again
uh
other brothers and allah reward them so
they do a lot of the work so
allah i mean really bless them for it uh
i'm
myself alhamdulillah i have a brother
yes he does my scheduling for the sake
of allah and allah reward him
uh and so there's a lot of other
brothers that kind of help out
um i you know my kids are all
homeschooled so
i mean it's not easy um obviously i have
my own personal reading
and writing and things that i want to do
from my own amman that i cannot
sacrifice so every night i have my own
reading time
even if it's at one or two a.m um
and then a lot of my family you know my
my family really supports
a lot of the things that you know
regularly i would be doing on the house
i don't because i'm busy with stuff and
they help out with that and uh
you know and then you just kind of ask
allah for help and
you know i last night i was up till
whenever doing you know the
daoa stuff and my own reading and stuff
like this and then in the morning i had
to get to work i was tired but
that's the thing with life i mean this
life is not for you to sleep out you
know you got you got to work hard
if you strive hard and do what you have
to do for the sake of allah in this life
then that cover that grave will be a
place of rest for you then you can catch
up on your
sleeping and resting and all that stuff
uh if not then
i mean imagine that punishment in the
grave would you prefer that i wouldn't
so
i gotta i gotta i gotta push myself you
know allah let me do it for a long
period of time and
you know and accept it from me
i mean i mean on her rami fill in bro we
got a few minutes left i don't want to
take up all the time
i was just going to ask does it get
easier over time
no doesn't get easier it gets harder man
you got more kids
right now and again i want to lose this
opportunity to apologize to everybody
that's been messaging that i haven't
been getting back to but
i literally have i'm going to give you
the actual number
so that i don't exaggerate um
i have thirteen thousand seventy-five
unread uh messages emails
thirteen thousand seventy-five uh i i
can't even imagine
how many else on twitter and and i don't
have a facebook personally because i
just don't have time for it
i don't have a snapchat i do have a
twitter which i started just to kind of
introduce people to
different books and things at abu
underscore
so that's i use twitter for uh kind of
introducing people to love students of
knowledge different books and best
friends and stuff
and whatsapp i mean i get like crazy
amounts of messages right now so
uh so it's difficult it doesn't get
easier it gets harder but you know
it's okay look it's not a choice
we have to do this right if not we
shouldn't be in this country
if we're not doing dawah why are we here
right the the good people
of this country that live around us our
neighbors our coworkers
deserve to know about islam i mean this
is their huff on us
so you know we got to do what you got to
do bro
allah very true right all right so
um forgive me if you said this at some
point in the video
because i'm not 100 here uh or if you
said this in a video on youtube
but what brought you to islam
how many minutes you got we got eight
minutes bro we can we can extend that a
little bit more bro
you do your thing you better extend it a
couple hours if you're gonna go there
but i'll give you the uh
short version of it so uh i was uh
i'm ethnically uh fashion from
pakistan uh but i was never raised there
like i came when i was a little kid we
moved to the uk
i lived there for a couple years then i
moved to the us when i was you know
whatever young
so i was never raised around muslims i
had no muslim friends growing up
i was raised in a very my parents didn't
really realize like what a good
neighborhood my bad never they thought
all of america was good so
we were in a bad neighborhood and i mean
grew up in a bad neighborhood got
involved with a lot of the
wrong side of tracks kind of stuff um
but there were some things that kind of
woke me up right
that one of them i will mention so i
grew up with a guy
manuel magana and he was mexican from
the same gang as me
two years older than me and there was a
setup to
actually kill me um but he went instead
because i went somewhere else and uh he
got shot
and he died and i was at his funeral and
i saw him get buried and
this i mean i have quite a few people i
grew up with that died
at least 12 that were like from my close
acquaintances
uh which you would call friends at the
time that are dead some by
you know playing russian roulette while
they're drunk some by
getting stabbed in the heart with a
screwdriver and stuff so i'd seen death
it's not that i hadn't
but this kind of really hit me because
it was supposed to be me and the way you
know
i mean this is before cell phone we had
pagers at that time
um so we got paged by a girl and
supposed to meet at a
particular pay phone we get there to set
up they come to blah blah blah blah
statue
and he got shot you know over all over
and
so i went to his uh funeral kind of woke
me up like you know
we were looking at drugs and money and
power and girls and things and
you realize like all of that does
nothing for you
um in the end he was going into a grave
by himself none of his girlfriends
the multiples that he had none of his
cars or
clothes or money or drugs or influence
went with him none of his friends none
of his gang
went with him it was just him and kind
of clicked in my head and
at that time then i started to do like
little soul-searching studies and
then i met some brothers masha'allah
very good brothers and
muslim brothers and alhamdulillah i
connected with them and
some of them i'm still connected with
alhamdulillah very good friends
and uh started to come towards the
realization that islam was the only
truth and
once you realize that then you think you
know i mean like look we got shot at
and all that stuff for what for gangs
for name for a name of a street or a
neighborhood that you didn't even own
some people for our color like you know
like really you know then when you come
to islam and people like oh
don't say you're a muslim be ashamed
like how can i be ashamed man i'm muslim
i'm proud of it
they shoot me for it alhamdulillah we
shaheed man like so what
we were gonna get killed from stupidity
you know
islam is something worth giving your
life for you know so
alhamdulillah allah blessed us with the
religion that
uh brings a pro you know in society a
peaceful
living between people and things we have
this message we need to share so
i mean it's a very long story i
shortened it for you but that's how i
came to it and then
you know i'm still a student i'm still
learning i'm
still a beginner you know and i
appreciate all those you and
that gave me their time for the sake of
allah to be able to study with them and
benefit from them
i hope that i continue that so
masha'allah do you have a a longer
version
on youtube or somewhere uploaded uh i
think there is i think inside
the film did an interview with me before
we kind of talked about my life and that
um i think there's a couple others that
during podcasts and stuff we've gone
over
if you guys want to do a longer version
we can uh next time
yeah yeah number two number two
definitely two man for sure
brothers and sisters if you made it this
far comment down below hashtag bring
sheikh uthman back for part two
inshallah
i got kidnapped or something
i would love to come back on i love you
guys man i like the way i like your vibe
you keep it real
i keep it fresh uh i see a lot of it's
lasting you guys
allah increase your uh goodness and a
lot
[Laughter]
yeah yeah there you go that's a good one
religion yeah
that's easy personal person what can
anybody have thoughts if allah made
something
nobody has a choice in it i think it's
uh i mean if you
have the ability to handle it and i
don't just mean physically
i mean emotionally i mean financially
um then sure go for it you know but
uh i think the problem with polygamy
today is that most brothers that do
engage in a polygamous marriage don't
handle it in the way of the sharia right
meaning they don't give time to their
kids anymore they don't
uh fulfill the hoboke of terbia of of um
any the ass so there's a physical aspect
obviously
but then there is also the spiritual
aspect right do you are you taking care
of your wife's
wives iman's and your children's iman
and that's where we see a lot of
shortcomings you see some brothers that
you know have three wives or whatever
and their kids are the worst in the
neighborhood
it's you know running around and that's
a problem um but you know anybody who's
ashamed of polygamy because they think
whatever
they're idiots i mean look allah knows
best
who created us allah who knows us best
who knows
think of it this way and i give this
example in the dollar videos all the
time right
let's say uh i'll just click on rami
because
right so rami let's say
you create a new um
device like it's a new phone it's not an
apple it's not a samsung it's not
you know some totally new technology
that is really cool and really advanced
like you open the phone you can smell
the person which i don't know if you
want to do that but
right you got holograms you can just
really it's like a
breakthrough technology right nobody's
got it you invent it mashallah you're so
intelligent right
and but it's obviously it's complicated
right it's very
so there's certain things you should do
with it or you shouldn't would you just
take it
and give it to somebody and say oh here
you go do whatever you want
no you're going to say you know what as
eddie come here if you ever bought a
cell phone
it comes with the user manual in the
medical device industry we call it ifu
instructions for use right so it comes
with how to use it hey
is it water you remember the old apple
phones if you if it got close to water
they break you know
um so they'd be like hey don't get it
wet you know don't do this because don't
mess it up right
you know don't don't put it in a
microwave you know don't do this don't
do that this is dangerous got a battery
like the old samsung that were growing
up in your lap right i got to be fair i
got to take shots both ways right
so right so you know those kinds of
things they tell you hey
this is what it can do this is how you
should use it this is how you should
charge it this is how you should
use it otherwise people won't know how
to use they'll misuse it
right allah created us allah made us and
allah is more intelligent than us allah
is
wiser than us obviously right every
every
even a christian or a jew or anybody
would agree right so then allah is not
going to leave us without
instructions of how to live these divine
texts whether we take what was revealed
to musa
these were instructions on how to live
right the only one that we have today
obviously is the quran
but if that allows something if allah
makes something
nobody has a right to question
in the comments write a hard question
for the shaykh inshallah for next time
we have them on for part two
why don't you guys just comment down
your questions and when we do it we can
do like a mini q a
can we get a million questions sent to
us that i don't get a chance to respond
to this is your chats
these guys have given you this
opportunity
what a wonderful note to end it on bro
if you guys have nothing else to say i
say we
end it off yeah if y'all made it this
far
hashtag bring sheikh uthman even
back and hashtag
muslim superman yes
i just wanted to get a quick thumbnail
pick because the frame for the thing
right
we already got it no i already got it
that's what i'm saying bro his head is
cut off
oh there you go you want to zoom out
just a little bit more
hey perfect all right
that's it that's it
for the one inflation yo act like you
got a gun
like you got a ak you guys want to go
there man
yeah yeah you got that ak just like this
you want me to get an ak and take a
picture
there we go there we go it's not up to
you to give
her your attention all the time because
if you do then you're you're missing the
point
you're not putting allah first right so
if you're not putting on
if you're not putting her first and
you're putting on love first she's gonna
be trying to get your attention all the
time
with her trying to get you attention all
the time she's going to be testing
she's going to be doing all these things
and if you fall into her frame
alas you're finished you're finished
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm